alors j'ai des winter comme vous êtes
croyante on va vous faire une interview
croyances
qu'est-ce qui se passe mais qui sont ces
gens là sont des gens qui désormais
habituel a pas d'accord cela dit on peut
encore s'exprimer
bien
à cannes où croyances ophélie winter est
ce que vous croyez en dieu
oui oui oui parce que pour la sacem
quand vous étiez enfant au lieu de vous
créer une espèce de vies parallèles
comme font les enfants avec des
personnages et où vous êtes et dieu
ouais moi c'est en fait j'ai compris
encore plus tard que c'était le manque
de père etc en fait au lieu de parler à
mon père je parlais à dieu tous les
moyens j'avais besoin d'un homme dans la
vie voilà est-ce que vous croyez à
l'amour oui oui j'y crois encore ouais
vous avez été assez tardive parce que
votre premier garçon où vous l'avez
connu quand j'avais 17 ans à ivry
relations sexuelles oui oui je n'étais
pas j'étais un mec c'était vachement mec
je traînais avec mon frère ouais tu vois
que tu es filles face à moi n'est pas
prête à l'emploi
j'avais pas de sens jusqu'à 17 ans quand
on voit là je n'ai pas le matos je vous
cherchez un père pour un bébé je cherche
un terme même un homme pour moi d'abord
cela les arrange personne et après
éventuellement vous dites il faut
quelqu'un qui m'aime pour mon âme et pas
seulement pour mon physique parce que
dans 20 ans j'ai le cul par terre et je
fais des nues avec mes seins c'est vrai
que c'est pas très encourageant non mais
c'est dur à trouver un mec je suis
paranoïaque là avec les mecs j'ai
l'impression que le jour je vais être
enceinte ils vont aller voter à droite à
gauche on ne sait pas ce qui va chercher
quoi comme genre de mec j'ai pas de gens
à la mecque avec qui je me marre qu'ils
soient gentils qui mènera c'est toujours
un tout le monde peut poser sa
candidature
bon ben voilà vous avez le site tout
formant partie sur france 2 pour cent
c'est la question de la fiche numéro 69
c'est vous qui me poser une question
les rôles sont inversés je vous écoute
69 questions thierry rouaix au caire
posez moi une question c'est est-ce que
tu m'aimes normalement j'aurais voulu
être la vérité c'est que j'aurais aimé
être ton pygmalion est ce que vous
croyez en vous maintenant oui depuis peu
je vouvoyais aux anges gardiens ouais
bon gardien c'est un fait en fait c'est
une un autre un autre nous dans un
espèce de l'univers parallèle comme ça
aux fantômes
oui un superman non non au père noël non
plus maintenant au pouvoir depuis quatre
jours ouais je vous voyez à l'effet des
crèmes antirides
non mais j'espère je me plais à y croire
de placebo la réincarnation vous y
croyez ouais voudrais vous raconter en
quoi branche à un mètre carré c'est de
vous fait dormir je voyais à céline dion
et alors tu à notre question mais si le
joker c'est cgil qui raconte quand on
répond pas ça passe à la personne d'un
côté c'est un risque
je dis non à ma première télé je crois
que penser d'une jauge a l'air con comme
si tu dis oui aussi
est ce que vous croyez à la mort d'elvis
presley
oui oui pas qu'il a éclaté sur les
chiottes qui prenait tellement de cachet
de gens pour dormir pour manger pour
maigrir pour l'un qu'il a éclaté je
croyais et de la fidélité dans le couple
et j'ai non maintenant au moins j'essaie
d'être moi je suis fidèle et je
vouvoyais l'amour sans sexe non non
quand on aime il faut que ça vous croyez
au sexe sans amour
ouais je suivrai que patrick fiori peut
se remettre de son aventure avec la raf
a redit le trop dur et souffrait qu'on
peut faire l'amour cinq fois de suite
ah oui je confirme des garçons la photo
du talon je vous réponds simplement
les solutions c'est le cd
gilles paquet brenner
les jolies choses